habt ihr ja da
waren dann kommt mal wieder nach berlin
da müssen wir mal zusammen im boxclub
etwa gamestage das wäre meine frage an
dich ruft man silber bruder das leben
als geil sei
ich glaube es ist sehr wichtig man hat
es aufgenommen
drei vier wochen ich weiß nicht erst
danach noch gesehen der war jetzt vor
zwei wochen getrocknet wissen waren das
hotel
ist einen draufgemacht aber vom feinsten
gehabt die ich bin in frankfurt ist so
wie du bist in frankfurt sagte er in
frankfurt zeigen was du bist dann gesagt
ich kenne das kommen des römers ich bin
direkt hingewiesen ich mag wenn sie das
ein regulativ nicht
hingefahren haben beträgt ein zimmer
genommen auch im gleichen hotel roomers
so ein geiles hotel bei uns habe ich
jetzt auch ein video gedreht
auch direkt eingecheckt und wir haben
unten die bar auseinandergenommen da hat
man also
500 euro rechnen haben wir gekriegt dass
wir direkt über neueste ist super kombi
stelle auch bezahlen war es da also
haben wir sowieso die rechnung wird an
constantin
zwar gehört die dosis kellertür
cool auch anders auch ein macher auf
jeden fall
er weiß wann er ernst sein muss und weiß
wann er lacht und mit dem wir gerne